have you ever wanted the incredible
performance of a MacPro but without that
incredible price tag well good because
today we're gonna show you step-by-step
how to build our official Mac Pro killer
PC and not only is it going to be a
third of the price of our Mac Pro but
it's also going to be faster pretty much
in every single way we have a faster CPU
a faster graphics card a faster SSD and
in general this thing is just going to
be crazy now as always we have links in
the video description to all of the
parts that you guys see here and I also
included some alternatives just in case
it is sold out or if the prices go up
stuff like that and for a few of these
parts I actually use them just because I
had them not because I would choose them
so then I'll throw in some alternatives
for you guys to check out let's take a
quick look at the parts before we get
started let's start off with a case and
for this one I knew I needed something
that is very high quality so we have to
be quiet dark bass pro 900 it's very
very nice as far as the building the
convenience features the build quality
is great with brushed aluminum and then
we have stainless and one very important
thing is the fact that it is quiet it's
designed to be quiet in an order 48 for
it to be an official Mac Pro killer it
has to have that now moving forward we
have the heart of this build and this is
the new thread Ripper 39 70 X it is an
incredible CPU 32 cores high frequencies
and hyper core efficiency which is
something the last generation did not
have so this is definitely going to be
able to compete I'm very looking forward
to that
now that chip is going inside of this a
Oris motherboard is an extreme addition
and this is a high-end motherboard that
offers a lot of features not only PCI
Express 4 but also has dual 10 Gigabit
Ethernet just like the Mac Pro a lot of
slots for adding cards multiple graphics
cards and of course it just has Wireless
built in and all the good features that
you want and then plugging into this we
have the ARS m2 SSD I got the one
terabyte option they have a larger one
as well but what's important is this is
a PCI Express 4.0
Oh SSD so it has twice the bandwidth
connecting to the thread Ripper and the
speeds here are going to be incredible
and they're gonna smoke the Mac Pros and
that's something that the Mac Pro cannot
offer it's stuck with PCI Express 3.0
now as far as RAM I have eight sticks
right here this is HyperX from kingston
they're predator Ram a really fast ddr4
and this total 64 gigabytes now if you
want more than that you can get larger
capacities and the bang for the buck is
pretty good there as well I just had
these sticks on hand personally I might
want to double that if you want
something that is incredible with lots
of RAM available and right next to it
over here I have a gigabyte add-in card
and this is very important it is
Thunderbolt 3 so in order to compare to
the Mac Pro we have to have that and not
only could this output Thunderbolt 3 but
it can actually actually accept an input
from our graphics card two inputs
actually so that it can send out a 6k
signal through Thunderbolt 3 and power
our pro Display XD our monitor because
you know once again to compete we want
that capability and we're gonna be
making it happen with this add-in card
so since I mentioned the graphics card
let's move over of course we need
something that can take on that Vega 2
in terms of performance and this is the
20 80 TI it is incredibly powerful
basically the best bang for the buck
graphics card right now if you want
performance it does not have as much
video memory but for almost most use
cases you do not need more than what
this graphics card offers so this is
going to be incredibly powerful next to
that we have our power supply this is a
750 watt from coolermaster and this
thing I would say maybe get a little bit
of higher wattage especially if you want
to overclock and use dual graphics cards
but I have this on hand and for our
build it's gonna be just fine but I will
have an alternative linked down in the
description and then to cool this
massive amount of power from the thread
ripper we have an enter max triple
radiator now this thing I already used
in a previous thread Ripper build one
thing it the one way it stands out is
that I can completely cover the CPU
which most coolers do not do that and
what that means it's going to give us
really really good performance now some
of the
other units had issues with leaking all
of the newer ones from last year or so
have been updated but just make sure if
you're buying one that you buy a new one
and if you don't want to take any
chances I'll link an alternative down in
the video description whoa what do we
have here this is something that I was
not expecting it was not listed for in
the motherboard but it was included this
is a hundred and fifty dollar PCI
Express 4.0 adding card that can accept
for MDOT two PCI Express for SSDs and
can raid them together for a total of
over 15,000 megabytes per second speeds
absolutely insane and this card has
actually sold out everywhere on Amazon
on Newegg on eBay so that is really cool
that if you buy this motherboard and you
can make use of this let's start out by
taking off one side of the m2 covers to
install our m2 SSD the screw that you
need is already there so take it off now
the m-dot two covers actually have a
thermal pad installed so it can cool
down your m2 but the one I bought which
is also from gigabyte or ARS has this
massive heatsink already there so if you
try to install it and then put the cover
back on it will not fit so your choices
are one take all of this apart or two
just leave that cover off and let the
built-in heatsink do its work and that's
what I'm gonna choose installing it is
simply just line up the little cutout
there gently push it in and then we're
gonna go ahead and put that little screw
back in now let's go ahead and install
our thread Ripper CPU and inside of the
box you have this little tool that is
basically kind of like a torque wrench
it's gonna put the proper amount of
torque when you're gonna install and
screw down the CPU socket and then you
do not want to take the frame off of the
CPU this is going to make it easy to
install and it's going to help to not
pend any pins on the motherboard which
is very important I'm gonna set it down
very carefully and right here on the
socket we have a little three a two and
A one it's going to signify how to open
and close it so all the instructions
aren't here we're going to start with
the third the second and the first to
open this up we have a plastic socket
cover that is here to protect the pins
and on a push down and release this
little guide
and then pull this out so this is shaped
just like our CPU frame grab our thread
Ripper CPU be very gentle take your time
we're going to slide that in there you
go and it locks in so you'll feel a
little bit of pressure there now push
down once again and now we're gonna
close this and then go ahead and screw
in in the opposite order so now we're
gonna start with one and then do two and
three and then when you're tightening
this down you want to keep going until
you hear this little click which means
there's enough pressure and that's why
you want this special tool now I'm gonna
move this aside and we are going to
start out with the case I really like
these side panels well you just have
these outside screws it makes it easier
and then it looks nice I wanna be
careful because this is real glass I
have to take a second and show off a few
things about this case that is
incredible as you guys can see we have a
lot of room here but we can actually
install these floating cages instead of
these little covers here and this allows
us to have five hard drives that are
just gonna float like this or you can
have actually ten SSDs because they can
be mounted as well whereas the Mac Pro
doesn't have any slots for any of that
you can buy a separate kit that holds
two and then we have other slots in the
back so there are a ton of different
add-in accessories that you can
customize this with and you flip this
around and the crazy thing about this
case is it's completely configurable so
this motherboard tray comes completely
out the whole back and come out you can
adjust height you can even do a reverse
build on the other side and by taking
all of this out it makes it easier to
build in now I'm not going to be doing
that today because for those of you guys
that might choose a different case you
guys are not going to have that option
but just these few screws you can take
out the motherboard plate all the hore
the whole thing and assemble it outside
and put it back in which is gonna be
fantastic we also have an eight fan
controller with two separate channels
and there's so much extra things like IO
on the front different things you can
customize with this case that I cannot
even cover but it is amazing we're gonna
start off by installing the power supply
now this case has this top shroud that
hides everything hides your wires
which is awesome let's flip this around
we have two more screws that are hidden
and now we can remove this whole cover
and now I'm going to remove these two
screws and then that will allow us to
slide out the hard drive little cage and
that is an extra step that you usually
don't have to do if you're installing
from the back but it does give us a lot
more flexibility if you want to move
things around in this case and now let's
put this little cage on our power supply
and there's going to be four screws that
are included with your power supply that
we're gonna install here now I already
have some cables plugged into my power
supply some of these are fully modular
means all the cables are separate and
you get to choose exactly what you need
some are half so I like that I don't
have to have a bunch of cables here I'm
gonna go ahead and feed all these cables
through little section in the back here
and before I put it down we need to go
ahead and plug in the power cable in to
this power supply so the the case comes
with its own separate switch and power
cable here and we want to make sure that
our power supply is set to on that's
because as soon as it's in here you're
not gonna have access to it you're only
gonna back sess to the switch in the
back we're gonna line it up to the same
screws that the cage came out of and
then slide it forward it's locked in
then replace the two screws now we're
going to install our motherboard once
again you can take that tray off we're
not going to do so and one great thing
about this nice motherboard is that it
has the IO plate on if you have a
cheaper one you're gonna have to first
put it into the case but this is all one
unit and typically you might have to add
extra standoffs to fit your motherboard
but this case is all set up it's ready
to go so we're gonna go ahead and insert
it and then the middle one actually will
kind of hang off of it
and I'll help you kind of be a guide to
you so you could do this laying down
it's easier I'm gonna do it this way
just to show you guys you know a better
camera angle so we're gonna set it right
here get it close to those little
standoffs and then carefully we're gonna
slide it back so that our i/o plate
matches up perfectly if it's properly in
place to Center little peg you can push
it in and they'll actually support the
motherboard and in our accessories box
we're gonna have the screws for the
motherboard they're the ones with the
bigger threads here and we're going to
screw those
down in five spots one two three four
and five and it really helps to have a
magnetic screwdriver for this you want
to make sure not to force it down as
soon as it stops that is good enough and
if it's not screwing in go ahead and
unscrew it and make sure that your
motherboard is lined up properly
now I'm going to go ahead and take off
this top cover there are little Clips so
you just push down with your thumbs up
over here over here and a little bit
further down to release it push down and
then you can remove the cover and there
we go
I'm gonna take my motherboard power
cables and then feed them through since
our motherboard is so huge it's actually
covering a part of this cutout here so
my fat 24-pin won't fit through unless I
want to remove the motherboard slightly
and get it through first so another
option is to take off one of these
little covers which you might be off
already if you have a hard drive cage
and when you're gonna route it through
here and then once again this will only
go in one way and you want to make sure
you push it all the way until you see
this part lock in and now it's time to
install our massive liquid cooling
system so I went ahead and I place this
up here and kind of got a reference
point of where it's going to attach and
unfortunately because this thing is so
massive and our motherboard also has
this really large heatsink right here at
the top it just barely barely doesn't
clear to be able to attach it if we had
a two fan radiator it could be moved
forward a little bit and worked or we
can attach it in the front but we're not
going to do that we're gonna go ahead
and lower the motherboard tray just a
little bit and this nice of this case
actually has a capability and then we're
gonna have enough room to attach
everything and now that we fixed that we
can finally install our water cooling
system as you guys see I already have
the fans on here if you guys get it out
of the box you're gonna have to screw
these in and this is where it helps to
have a second set of hands to hold that
up for you or you can lay the case down
and just kind of hold it in place get a
few screws aligned and then finish it up
our fan cable is going to connect to the
gray one and then the pump is going to
connect a little bit later to the one
next to it if you're installing this for
the first time you're gonna have a full
tube of thermal
paced and I would do a nice line down
the center and then when we apply even
pressure it's gonna squish out you we
don't want to overdo it my first time I
use probably bout 3/4 of this and it's
still on there I'm gonna take a little
remaining bit and just apply it here at
the center for this part it's best to
lay the case down and we're gonna align
these screws with right where it needs
to go on the socket and then when you're
screwing down the waterblock you don't
want to just get one and screw it all
the way down we want to start off with
one of them and then move to another one
just so they all attach once you're done
you can attach your water blocks power
connector right next to the other CPU
fan connection it's labeled CPU optional
and now let's go ahead and install it
Ram we have the slots right over here
four on each side and we have these
little locks just at the bottom so you
want to go ahead and open them up and I
have eight six of RAM and if you have
four or two you want to check the manual
of the motherboard they'll tell you
exactly which slots to use for your
different configurations but on these
RAM sticks we actually have a little
notch and that's how you know where to
place them and there's a notch on the
motherboard and it'll only go in one way
so once it's open
you wanna align your RAM stick and then
if it's not going in that means it's the
wrong way so we're gonna flip this and
then align it again and it does take
some efforts I'm going to push on one
side push on the other and then the lock
will actually automatically engage so
all of the RAM slots on this side are
gonna face one direction and then the
ones on the other side are gonna face
the other direction now before we
install our Thunderbolt card or the
graphics card I want to deal with some
of these cables now we lower the
motherboard over here and it makes a
little bit more difficult to access this
bottom panel maybe it'd been good to
connect those first of course we can
remove this slide it out to remove these
two screws and have full access but I'll
just show you exactly where we're going
to plug in down here we're going to have
two different connections our front
audio and then our Thunderbolt three
card connector next we're going to
connect our front USB a ports and our
USB C port our USB 3 connections are
right over here
yeah in our USB type-c connector is
right up here and now we're going to
connect our fan controller that has a
bunch of fans plugged into it to the
motherboard we're going to go through
the top here and it's going to connect
right in the span section and it only
goes in one way
and now we're going to connect the rest
of their front panel connections here
with this motherboard it makes it really
easy because it comes with this g
connector meaning that we can connect
everything externally and then we're
going to plug it into here and then
connect the other side to the motherboy
it's going to make it much more simple
just slide each connector into place and
they'll lock in and if you don't know
which one's positive this little arrow
signifies the positive so once it's all
plugged in you can go ahead and attach
it to this little adapter we're going to
pass it through and it's going to attach
right here now for our fan controller we
have two of these SATA connections for
power so I am gonna have to add another
cable to my power supply that way I can
connect this and I'm gonna go ahead and
plug these in they only go one way so
you don't need to force them and we'll
plug the other end into our modular
power supply and then if you want to
make use of the included LED strips
we're gonna tape those down wherever you
want them and then run the cables to the
back and that is going to connect to our
fan controller in the RGB sections and
now it's time to add in our Titan Ridge
Thunderbolt card and our graphics card
for that I'm gonna have to remove four
covers back here four of the slot covers
we're gonna skip the top one remove the
next three because our twenty atti has a
massive heatsink that takes up three
slots and we're gonna skip one and then
remove one more at the bottom for the
add-in card I'm gonna start off with the
Thunderbolt three card
align the pins here press in and we'll
go ahead and screw this one in I'll
start out by connecting our Thunderbolt
connector here well go ahead and connect
our USB 2 connection here we're going to
connect it to the usb adapter and
splitter that comes inside the
motherboard box and they're gonna pass
this through to the other side there and
that's going to connect right there and
now we're going to connect power to the
Thunderbolt this is the same kind of
as a graphics card but you only need two
6-pin so we don't need the little
additional ones and that's time to put
in our crazy 2080 TI
that has a huge huge heatsink here so
we're gonna align it once again to the
slots make sure the lock is open and
push down evenly and now we can go ahead
and screw in two three screws and for
our last power connector we have for the
graphics card here and this one of
course needs all eight pins from each
set so a total of sixteen now before we
put the power supply shroud on and all
the covers on the top and all of that
it's always good to plug it in first
make sure that it boots up because if
you have one cable that's not connecting
or something like that you have to take
it all apart so I plugged it in right
there and I have a little HDMI monitor
for my camera that I'm going to use I
don't to get my whole you know monitor
out here and there we have it we have
LED lights we have fans and then I'll
look on my little monitor here to see if
we get a signal with the BIOS popping up
here and there we have it the fan spun
down the bias is showing up so let's go
ahead and put all the covers back on so
I have my 4k monitor right here I'm not
yet gonna test out the 6k XDR monitor
that's going to be after we get windows
installed but I do want to show you guys
how we make that connection from the
graphics car to the Thunderbolt 3 card
and then out to Thunderbolt 2 the
display so we have 2 of these cables
that are included in the box we're gonna
connect the mini display ports to the
input of the Thunderbolt 3 card and then
on the other end the full-size display
ports are gonna connect to our graphics
card now that might seem weird to have
to do that but that's what we need to do
to get a crazy enough signal to do 6k
with 10 bit HDR but like I said I'm not
gonna test this just yet we are gonna
connect our regular 4k display alright
guys here we are in the BIOS we are
showing our 32 core 39 70 AMD CPU it's
idling at 38 Celsius which is great so
what I'm gonna do now is I'm gonna grab
my Windows 10 USB stick and this could
be created for free from Microsoft's
website I'm gonna insert it and we're
gonna restart to start up
our setup and we'll leave a link in the
video description where you can go and
create one of these for yourselves so
when we start the system up as soon as
he the BIOS screen we want to just keep
hitting f12 that's gonna get us our boot
menu now I just had one issue show up
when I was trying to load in my USB
windows drive as soon as I would put the
USB stick inside of the computer and
then try to boot it would give it would
really not turn on and then on the
motherboard I was having oh D as far as
the error code and so what I ended up
doing is I'm plugging in that USB Drive
and then as soon as I see the ars logo
that's when I would plug it in and then
hit f12 so that this boot menu comes up
and that work perfectly so now we see
our gigabyte a terabyte of ultra-fast
nvme SSD and then the flash drive over
here so I'm gonna select that partition
and here we go we have our window set up
I'm gonna hit install now if you don't
have a product key just click I don't
have a product key and they'll still let
you install Windows I'm gonna go with
the home version because that's what I
do have a product key saved for but you
could do the pro if you have that we
want to select the custom option because
we're doing a new installation and then
here we have our one terabyte SSD
showing up us 931 I guess there's a lot
of space that's saved just in case so
I'm gonna click on that hit new and then
hit apply to keep the default size and
then it's going to create a couple
different partitions that windows needs
there we go and then we're just gonna
hit next and there we have it windows is
installing so there we have it we are
all done with our thread Ripper step by
step build the system that's gonna be
taking on my personal Mac Pro make sure
you guys have notifications enabled if
you guys want to check out that video
and you can go in your BIOS you can
change your memory profile to set it to
the proper speed of the one the RAM that
you bought and then go on from there
installing your programs we're doing
windows update all of that good stuff
and using it just like any normal PC let
us know if you have any questions down
in the comments section below once again
we have links to all of the parts that
we personally used along with some
alternatives and some suggestions for a
few of the parts that you know I
probably would do something different
with because I did own a few of these
parts here
so you guys can go and check those out
click that little circle above to
subscribe and check out a couple other
great videos right over there one of
which may already beat the Mac Pro
comparison if that is out this by Max
and I'll see you in the next video
[Music]